welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about what it takes
to get some damn justice in this world
of superhumans gone crazy yes they
deserve to die and i hope they burn in
hail that was my impression i'm jessica
clements with me today is none other
than brandon barrack
brandon well jessica's so great to have
you back on big question we're not in
person this time though what a bummer i
know i went back and watched that one
that we did in person it is a very fun
big question should be done in person
just for the editors to have fun with
what we're doing in our like in the area
next to each other but it's okay we'll
still have fun we'll still have fun are
you ready oh we'll have a great time so
brandon i got a question for you i got a
big question for you
what's today's big question
okay well then i have a big question for
you uh with the she-hulk series
premiering later this summer on disney
plus we got our first look at what the
show is gonna be about from a trailer
that released a couple weeks ago we all
know it we all love it we had no
complaints about the cgi our mean green
judicial machine is going to be
representing superhumans on behalf of
the department of justice as they face
trial for their crimes but how does one
even go about representing a super
villain in a regular person's courtroom
okay it all leads us to this week's big
question how are super villains defended
in the courtroom of the mcu
oh we did it we knew what we were doing
i feel like we need like the like the
people's court intro right but yeah
yeah
all right jessica this is the people's
car of the mcu and everyone deserves a
fair trial here no matter how heinous
the crime okay it's a bedrock of modern
and civilized society that we're able to
offer everyone their day in court right
we all get it doesn't matter if you got
tentacles coming out of your back you
still deserve your day in court you get
the right to a fair trial all right
shout out to doc ock shout out to doc
[ __ ] even he gets his day in court okay
but when humans are no longer equal in
terms of powers and abilities how do we
adjust the judicial system to keep it
fair right because these aren't just
like normal people they're very powerful
people who have a lot of power can't be
trusted out there right
so let's consider a couple things when
we're gonna start bringing these super
humans to trial okay the first thing we
should think about is like who is wrong
here or like is it people is it property
or whatever is it is it an individual
person is it a whole city is it a state
is it a whole country is it like the
whole planet is the whole planet been
wronged by someone right that's
something we have to consider and i
think for most of this let's think about
emil blonsky right aka abomination all
right he's sitting in a cell at that
that prison complex they showed us he's
got to go to trial right if we think
about the crime he committed it's mostly
involved all that stuff that happened in
harlem uh with the incredible hulk right
tearing up harlem now hulk
was doing stuff in there too and all i
know is if he doesn't face any trial for
this i think that's a little unfair
right granted hulk did work to bring
everyone back blah blah blah blah blah
but emil blonsky was locked up he was
not able to help in that situation maybe
he would have gotten some amnesty if
that were the case
yeah 100 100 but i'd
continue going with your theory okay so
if if if we're talking uh to emil
blonsky here and he's on trial or maybe
abominations on trial if it's the same
person they're on trial uh we'll say
it's like the state of new york is going
to go after them yeah for what happened
in in new york city um so what laws are
we going to apply to this guy right are
these normal laws or new laws that are
put into place to govern the activity of
like superhumans
uh let's take a the biggest example we
have this is like the sokovia accords
right and these were like international
laws signed by a bunch of different
countries now his actions took place
before the sokovia of course
so maybe they're they're not in place
here right he can't be tried under those
although now that the new laws are in
place he could be tried under the
sokovia courts wait he can still be
is that how
is that how law works
can you tell well my
and my understanding of it he hasn't had
his trial yet if that's the trial he's
up for here okay so if there was like
the purge laws right and i stole a car
during the purge and then it's the next
day do i get in trouble when i'm trying
to like
you know
if you're operating under the laws of
the purge no but if like if you commit a
crime under the laws of the purge uh and
then the laws change but you haven't had
your trial yet you might be able to be
tried under these new laws i don't i got
put into place true okay maybe i maybe i
just don't know how the law works is why
it works it works both ways though right
a lot of people who are in jail uh for
marijuana convictions are getting those
convictions overturned because the laws
have been changed right uh so it kind of
works both ways in that scenario and i'm
pretty sure the sokovia chords are still
in effect because of what we saw in one
division right i would do that if i was
abomination then i'd be like okay
okay wait wait wait when i tore up the
city things were very different okay it
was okay for us to be doing that we were
in harlem that's what we do
we were in harlem there was blood
floating around people were taking
seriously it was crazy time it was crazy
the fact okay this is now we're getting
into a this is a big question always
does this big question always does this
right
who
made obama abomination uh that shouldn't
be my fault i'm gonna get to that we're
gonna get i'm gonna you're you're you're
getting into jennifer's case here that's
not me that's her biggest defense it's
who made obamacare yeah there you go but
all right so let's say right now in the
mcu the sokovia accords are still in in
place because uh hayward said during the
events of wanda vision that they were
able to get vision's body because of the
sokovia courts and he was doing all that
cutting it up and doing all that messed
up stuff because of the jurisdiction he
had from the sokovia courts which is
kind of messed up like sword what i
understand is like a us government
operation but it might not also be
international they might have allowed
other people to come in replace shield
because shield was uh infiltrated by
nazis uh hello come on or hydra but
hydra are not they're like nazis plus
yes
so yeah bit of a problem and now they've
got a new government organization
overseeing this stuff i don't know if we
should trust it so we have abomination
he's on trial in the state of new york
the sokovia courts apply to him whatever
we don't know the the techie laws in
there but there's certain jurisdictions
that are in there uh but how are we
gonna try this guy okay we have to think
about are we gonna have like a civilian
court or like a military tribunal uh and
like that's something they did the
nuremberg trials are like kind of like
uh they were like a whole new set of
legal procedures that were set up
because they were like how do we even
put nazis on trial we gotta have like a
whole new system so you have like your
civilian court which we're all pretty
familiar with judge jury all that all
that razzmatazz there's like a military
court which is very different it's like
a tribunal there is a jury but it's very
different and then you can have like
just a whole new legal system that you
set up so how we're gonna try these
super villains it's like very important
if we're gonna have a civilian trial
with like a jury we need to consider how
do we give abomination like an impartial
jury okay
so we're bringing him up on charges uh
for his actions in harlem his defense uh
like jennifer walters might be able to
argue like oh we can't even have this
trial in new york city because we can't
have an impartial jury right yeah
because everyone everyone they were
reading the papers you know the new york
post is talking about it like
abomination station or that's a terrible
headline
but they have a much better handle about
it
abomination station
something like that i think they they
tore up a subway station a little bit so
yeah that's what makes sense
we'll throw it on the pile for potential
headlines um so that that might be the
argument but you know there have been
cases where they found that like you
could have the case in the city where
the crime happened if it was a big crime
uh the a federal court decided that the
boston marathon bomber could be tried
inside of boston even though that's
where the crime taking place they're
like no you can have an impartial jury
here a lot of times they move it out of
the city so we could do that with
abomination right we could move it out
of new york city uh
that's what they differ from for
abominations i know there's abomination
to like just humans
well
yeah yeah so you like they moved oj and
like the oklahoma city bomber they did
those outside of the cities where the
crimes took place but you know i think
the prosecution could argue like we
there's no reason to move it because the
whole country knows about obamacare yeah
exactly uh it would be a huge news story
it would be impossible to find an
impartial jury anywhere so let's just
have it in new york city 100 uh right
but then you know but this is also like
the mcu where people are reading about
crazy [ __ ] every day so people might not
even like care about about abomination
happened before the attack that is that
is for thanos before the eternals before
all this other stuff so it's like people
might just be sick of him they'd be like
i don't even remember obama that was
nothing oh he just destroyed half a
block no
is that the purple guy
was that the robot guy
was that the guy
he picked up the city and dropped it
that was that guy i don't even know
anything is that the one in the tights
is that the one in the time they all
wear does he have tights he's the green
guy that talks not the green guy who
doesn't talk right yeah the one that
does it or does talk which one is it
i think that either way i don't like
both of them i think that is also a very
thing a good thing to keep in mind
because i'm like yeah i guess as a
humans i'd still vote abomination guilty
because i'm a human but then i'm like i
guess i'm in the mcu world where i'm
like this happens every like
tuesday thursday i
mean abominations crimes at this point
seem so minuscule so minuscule right
compared to everybody else oh 100 but i
also think that's why i think i'm
leaning more towards the military
tribunal i think that's also what the
mcu would do and she would defend him in
the military tribunal to like excessive
i don't know uh death i get i don't even
think he can he die can we kill him um
well that's a that's a good point like
how do we we have to consider how we're
even gonna what the punishment is yeah
with the
person it seems like he's already being
punished locked in solitude forever well
i guess long is letting him leave well
and here's here's the thing to consider
also right you're gonna have this trial
in the first place uh we're gonna have a
fair trial that means there's a
possibility he could get off right he
could be acquitted
now does he pose a threat to let him go
exactly we even let this man go you know
what i mean 100 so we're so i think like
we can't even have like a civilian trial
right because in theory like you
couldn't even have this guy in the in in
the courtroom it's not safe for the jury
order or whatever and i don't think a
civilian a normal civilian trial under
the way we understand it here in our
universe would work for this guy we got
to change things a little bit so if
we're going to go for a non-traditional
trial set up in a legal system that we
already know and understand then we have
to build a new legal framework from
scratch
uh for these procedures to take place uh
so this is very similar to what they did
uh for the nuremberg trials okay like i
mentioned earlier uh because after world
war ii they were like how do we even put
the nazis on trial uh and ever all the
allies they debated about how they would
uh try the nazis for war crimes right
the u.s they wanted like a fair trial
like there has to be a fair trial
because we have to show that like we're
the good guys they're the bad guys black
the soviets they just wanted like a show
trial so they could present all the
evidence and say like here's why we
deserve a ton of reparations because
they killed 27 million of us right uh
the british the british just wanted like
summary executions they're like we don't
need a trial just kill these
[ __ ] right like we come from
medieval times
we want to just kill these guys right
slice and dice we'll slice and dice and
dip out right we'll come over there help
you guys
get out
yeah england was bombed to smithereens
right they're like just kill these guys
we hate this right
uh so there was a lot of debate around
how to even do this and and so they like
i said they came up with a whole new
legal framework right uh all the
countries agreed on the nuremberg
charter which was a framework to charge
individual people for breaches of
international law rather than the whole
state so this was like a big difference
right normally for like crimes against
humanity which was kind of came up
during the nuremberg charter it's like a
whole new thing for war crimes you would
charge like a state right you would
charge germany in general like they
wanted a way to charge individual people
acting on behalf of the state so that's
why they came up with the whole
nuremberg charter and that that was like
totally new and oh the funny thing about
the nuremberg charter right was like
only germans could be prosecuted under
the nuremberg charter not any of the
actions taken by the allies so no one
could be like well america you did some
messed up stuff during world war two
it's like no no this ain't our trials no
no no no no this is just for the nazis
just in germany not me i didn't do that
oh my god
what happened here yeah we're all trying
to find the guy who did this and give
him a spanking so they could do that in
the mcu right they could come up with
this new legal framework and say like
only only superhumans could be charged
under some of these things or only those
we did we deem as villains in civil war
we can tell that giving them a laws
don't really do anything
and that's right it comes down again to
like the watchmen like who watches the
watchman it's like who watches the
superheroes unless we have
literally carol danvers that wants to be
the police on earth with these
superheroes they're going to keep doing
whatever they want to do you know yeah i
thought that was very yeah yeah exactly
you can't stop how do we stop these
people this is what the boys is what the
voice talks about right yeah we can't
stop can't stop them
it's insane
and i think it was very interesting in
the trailer that the guy mentions like
super humans he doesn't say superheroes
he doesn't say super villains he's a
superhuman
so this way they're just like it's a
blanket anyone with powers can be tried
here right yeah yeah so that's how it's
gonna work i think they'll definitely do
that i think that's a good way of going
about it that they'll make like a new
law that like blanket covers like
superheroes they get tried differently
but or superhumans they get tried
differently
but it's just also like
if there are villains it's like a
villain's thing to not show up to court
[Laughter]
right and you could look at someone like
baron zemo right if he gets caught
[Music]
oh can you try him as a superhuman or is
he not because he's just a normal
powered person right but he might be
subject to like superhuman laws but i
think if you have the power to do those
things then you have then you should be
tried like a superhuman does that make
sense i guess it's like oh okay okay
i'm saying put all the rich in it uh
try the rich in the same way i i think
it's because i'm i'm mainly leaning
towards like i'm not saying batman is
bad but if batman did right i mean i
mean
yeah
that was kind of bad i misspoke i
misspoke i spoke too soon um this is
where you insert the clip for batman
returns where he throws the guy down the
chimney and then throws a bomb down
there okay
[Music]
that man is bad so it's if you tried
batman it's like oh well he doesn't have
any superpowers it's like no but he's
very smart he knows every sort of combat
and he fights alongside superhumans yeah
i think we should still try him in the
same legal man and he's breaking the
lock and he's breaking the law right
dude
because all of his actions involved
superhumans so maybe you could like be
like he's a associate or a uh
i don't know all of his actions involve
superhumans yes so you could you could
try them that way um but let's think
about our boy emil right so we're having
this trial for him and like i said we
have to think about like could he get
off is it is there a risk of him being
free is it too great why have this trial
in the first place uh because as you
were pointing out and i think this is
very fair could emil blonsky you know
could his defense be that he was misled
by a government official we all remember
thunderbolt ross yes kind of tricked
that guy into becoming what he was right
at first he's like oh i need you to go
get this guy and he's not really telling
him all the details he gives him a
little juice right he's like i'll give
you a little juice because this guy's
can be strong he's not telling him
what's up and emil blonsky gets his back
broken because he was lied to by a
government official operating on behalf
of the government right
and so then he takes more juice and he
becomes the abomination he didn't plan
on that right no he was a soldier doing
his job maybe as a mercenary a little
questionable but he was misled by a
government official right could he plead
insanity could he could he be like i was
turned into a giant monster i should not
be held accountable for my actions right
i think he can easily and that's the
plea that i think that if uh jennifer
was uh defending him could be like he
didn't ask for this like he was misled
to do this i mean
yeah his actions were horrible but it's
also like
this wouldn't have happened if
thunderbolt ross didn't inject him
like none of this would have happened
unless you remember the hulk was a big
threat at that point yeah he was i mean
terrorized he was everything bruce was
trying to be calm he was trying to stay
away from stuff trying to become trying
to be safe but he was a threat to
everybody he was considered a threat in
the mcu all through like avengers to the
end of avengers when he's like it's okay
i'm always angry i'm in control now
remember when he almost killed natasha
almost killed natasha yes okay
this guy's a monster it was like up
until thor ragnarok where i was like oh
yeah he's like conscious of what he's
doing now
like because
rocky was like and it still was a
beating up on him and thor ragnarok to
realize that he like demolished a lot of
things
but it took a lot for hulk to recognize
that like
he's also bad he's also bad sometimes
yeah he's also bad so so we're building
the the legal proceedings from scratch
here we can determine what precedence we
need to be met in order to like either
lock emil blonsky away or like set him
free and he complete insanity sure like
we could we could set up a thing where
like if you're a superhuman and you're
on trial and you want to plead insanity
that's fine but by you pleading insanity
it doesn't mean you get off scot-free it
means you get put into some sort of
facility for the rest of your life okay
because if we're making our own legal
proceedings we can say the rule how the
rules are going to work here right so
maybe that's what we saw in chongqi
right maybe emil blonsky is like yes i'm
a superhuman i did some bad things i'm
pleading insanity and they're like fine
you're locked away forever that's the
deal and you can go on like work release
with uh wong and go fight in tournaments
and stuff but you're still our prisoner
and that's how it's going to work
that's what's going to happen you need
to get like work release i i pitched
that i think this is what's happening
maybe now when he's in there he's like i
want to re i want to be like retried i
want to be retried and that's why
jennifer's working oh okay and i think
that like his little sponsor is wong and
helping him like get his anger out
because i feel like in in all prison
they usually allow uh inmates to have
like one outlet whether it's like
working in a library or doing art or
whatever what have you i i unfortunately
don't know too much about
what people do in prison i just know
fortunately i don't like that i think
that's fortunate yeah i just know why i
don't like prisons i know i could never
go i wouldn't survive i would not
survive my mom has told me horror
stories and i don't need to know i don't
need to go i don't need to go she's done
she's i've watched i've watched enough a
e to know i could never survive a prison
yeah
i watched enough uh orange is the new
black edit that out because that is not
what prison is maybe that is not
prisoners no no no no but no i do think
that yeah so if wang's his sponsor i
think that's like his little like his
free time he that's his like yeah yeah
i'm i'm getting better and i do have a
feeling deep in my heart that
abomination is getting better like eli
roth is like eli roth eli roth the
horror movie yeah
it's getting better
emil bronski emil blonsky
why is that eli roth what is it you like
cause you got it in your head i don't
know i love him i don't know i don't
know why i did but emil blonsky i think
he's getting better i do think he's
getting better and he's like i'm ready
to go like i've found a way to
internalize my anger with like in fights
with wong uh just like boxing and i
think i'm ready to go i'm free i'm good
i i really hope on this show at some
point bruce and emil talk i mean that's
gotta happen i would be so mad if i was
a meal looking at bro i would be so mad
that's what that would be like why is
this guy does the same [ __ ] that i did
he did it worse because at least i got
put away he did it for like four more
movies yeah
well and i wonder like
on agents of shield they implied that
like abomination was like frozen kind of
like they didn't know how to like
because remember abomination doesn't
like
in the comics traditionally and uh in
the movie he couldn't like revert back
to a meal form yeah
right clearly they found a way to do
that we saw in the trailer but like in
theory he was on ice according to agents
of shield now that's like a different
universe still it's not connected or
it's a branch timeline i don't know how
it works but if they do come back and
say like yeah he was frozen for a while
we unfroze him because we figured out
how to like de-power him and now he saw
the news and saw bruce is walking around
and he's pissed like that could be like
i love this idea like he's filed an
appeal and he's like i went out cause
this is [ __ ] yeah this is yeah oh
honestly yeah honestly and also a little
triggering to see jennifer as like hulk
i'd be like oh yeah yeah right i'd be
like another one why can't y'all just
leave me alone why can't you leave me
alone you don't terrorize everybody oh
well let's let's talk about how a meal
is imprisoned right yeah they're already
keeping these like superhumans like
locked up right we've seen the raft
which was already in the mcu presumably
set up under the ocovia accords though
it clearly had to have been built way
before they were signed because tony's
like we signed these accords and also
there's this big prison underwater like
that didn't happen overnight dawg they
were working on that for a while
[Music]
and that makes sense like shield would i
think shield and like nick fury's smart
enough to be like if super humans exist
and this problem exists we need to set
up a prison that could hold them we'll
have the raft right
um and that's smart because it could
have been in the international waters we
don't know for sure like in the comics
it's just off the coast of new york but
it would be smart to put it
international waters because then you
can do whatever you want out there you
don't have to follow the rules of like
the us constitution and stuff like that
uh we'll get into that a little bit
later but this new prison that we saw on
the show we think it's the cube
right it appears to be in the nevada
desert or some sort of desert but if it
is
on american soil then there's different
rules right because uh we have laws that
protect prisoners on u.s soil uh it's
kind of why we set up guantanamo bay
because at guantanamo bay which is in
cuba prisoners can be held indefinitely
without trial which goes against the
sixth amendment but if we're saying emil
blonsky is in the cube he's on u.s soil
then the sixth amendment would like
protect him which says you have the
right to a public trial without
unnecessary delay unnecessary delay is
played within legalese a lot can go for
years unfortunately but that may be the
case so we're saying like blonsky's here
he's on u.s soil if he's going to get a
trial it's got to happen that makes
sense i get that
which makes you worried if like the raft
is still out there and there's there's
people on the rafter they're like we're
never putting this person on trial i
don't know i don't i think this is also
a wake-up call to other people that are
locked up that are like oh wait i can
ask like we got a defender now
i can ask to go to trial i get asked to
go to trial for which is a lot of prison
[ __ ] is like people don't know the their
rights a lot of people don't know what
they can do and also you're swayed to
believe that you can't do what you can
do and so i feel like in this it'd be
like once he's like doing all this [ __ ]
they're like we have an actual inhuman
person defending us i want someone that
has to deal with my struggles defending
me and they have
because i feel like a lot of defenders
for the people that are inhuman are
super inhuman uh are like also just
normal humans that are like i don't like
you already
yeah yeah yeah i already have a this
makes sense yeah yeah and that guy in
the trailer was like we want to make you
the face of yes right because you're
superhuman and that's great that's what
we need to to show that like superhumans
are defending other superhumans that's
how it's going to work because in the
comics jennifer walters she most
famously works for goodman lieber
kurtzberg and holloway who work under
the superhuman law division of new york
it seems like they're going in a similar
route on this show you know we kind of
saw a symbol that looks like uh the
department of justice symbol and it
would make sense that this would be like
more of a federal thing more than a new
york thing i know we're saying like you
know his actions were in new york so
maybe the state of new york is trying
but i'm sure the federal government
would want to get involved here jennifer
often works on cases that sat before a
jury in the comics and it kind of looks
like in the show she's gonna be in front
of a joy that that shot of like titania
busting through a wall it looks like
there's maybe like a jury or something
in there but it you know it could be
difficult to bring a jury together due
to impartiality reasons or safety
concerns do we think jennifer will be
able to appeal directly to the people on
this show like that seems to be her
advantage in the comic books is that she
can talk to a jury right it's going to
take a minute but i think recognizing
that
with whatever the fans have to say but
she's still like a woman she is not a
hulk you know what i'm saying right
right right she still has like the
office is that gonna be her closing line
ladies and gentlemen
so i think that's going to be the
winning thing i feel like a lot of um
even with um
oh captain mayonnaise uh
what's his name
oh us agent john walker
it's like johnny mayonnaise
[Music]
you have to give something to the people
that appeal to the people make them feel
safe it's a so i don't agree with it
clearly but like this is just how we
live as humans in america uh and so i
think seeing an inhuman would be scary
but seeing it a inhuman that has the
features of a normal human she's just
green it's a very tall
so i think they're like oh this is a
person on my green beans can like i'm
into this this is fine with me
like i'm a member of the jury and this
is the jolly green giant and i'm okay
with it i used to eat this for breakfast
i agree look you're not getting teeth
you didn't eat green beans for breakfast
no not usually
okay well don't don't don't don't knock
it till you try it don't know
it sounds good actually i love some
green beans
[Music]
that's a good point johnny mayonnaise
right his his trial was like a military
tribunal style right he had several
members of the military no jury like
that's how it worked there they're like
when i put you in front of a cherry boy
no you're guilty
that not gonna happen oh johnny
mayonnaise was really bad too because he
just like publicly executed someone made
like yeah yeah right that he could not
have gone in front of as also it's like
the military that created him and wanted
him to be the new captain america and be
the face so it's like hey yeah we
recognize we gotta deal with this
problem like you messed up my dude
yeah and we've seen that before like the
military doing that with like the case
of like the american sniper dude right
he went before like a military tribunal
like that's how it works but yeah it
would make sense to
that like even if if uh jennifer walters
isn't gonna appear before like a jury
trial fully she could appear before like
a grand jury which sometimes happens
before a trial even happens they'll do a
grand jury which is kind of separate
from the regular courts where they they
bring in a jury it's usually secret you
don't know who's on the grand jury uh
and it's just to present evidence to see
if there's enough standing to even have
a case in the first place now there's so
much evidence here right i mean as you
pointed out with like johnny mayonnaise
they got footage of him like bashing a
dude skullin with abomination there's
plenty of evidence right there's plenty
of footage people saw it witnesses we
know there's enough to have a case here
so i doubt they're gonna have like a
grand jury situation here but they could
if they're not gonna have a jury for the
main court you could have like a grand
jury and she could do it there in the
comics the court cases uh that we have
seen they do seem to fall under like
standard procedures and rights that we
have in our universe right they fall
under the us constitution
and just like in our universe in the
comics and presumably the mcu they'd be
subject to new laws that can be made by
the government as well as executive
orders released by the president right
there's been some really funny legal
precedents that have been established in
marvel comics that i found for instance
like aliens like aliens from outer space
they have no legal standing in the u.s
and therefore there's like no laws to
protect them to protect them
yeah yeah they're they're not like for
they're not for sure governed by like
u.s laws they don't get like the
protections that like an earthling would
necessarily get okay
but we know jennifer walters has
defended eros right in his sexual
assault trials there's there's evidence
there for that this one was interesting
ghost like ghosts previously had no
rights in a court of law because they're
ghosts but that decision got reversed
due to the implication of the infinity
gauntlet affair in the case of thanos
versus the universe uh this actually
happened in a she-hulk comic from
she-hulk number three from 2004 when
jennifer is able to successfully argue
the ghost of billy briggs to take the
stand and provide testimony can you
imagine
how that would change courts everywhere
if ghosts could provide testimony i
don't think they'll be crazy they would
literally be like hearsay like they
would be like unfair or whatever they
say but this is a world where ghosts
exist right the ghost knows the answer
also it was
[Laughter]
failure breaks took the stand as a ghost
i mean that's how it's going to happen
right like that'll be crazy i mean in
shanghai we know people have souls right
if you could get a soul from the
underworld to bring it back that's true
you could if you could break into the do
what and grab someone and bring them
back
can you provide some testimony
the panther from black panther it's just
a giant okay can you turn back into a
human before oh yeah the ancestral yeah
the ancestral plane right be like hold
on let me let me call my grandpa
plane he's gonna provide some excellent
testing he's a cat right now but maybe
in like 10 minutes it'll turn back into
a union another funny thing was like uh
the state of new york it doesn't have
any laws to protect the life liberty and
happiness of non-human life forms
therefore you can't have charges pressed
upon
like uh the murderer of a non-human life
form you can't like press charges on
that so if uh i guess in this instance
it's group right so
is he's also an alien so he has no
protections on our planet if he's killed
by a person like say guru's walking down
the street someone stabs him and kills
him or uses a herbicide or pesticide on
him and kills him right that person
can't be tried because he's a non-human
life form it's he's not government so he
can just go off and kill like any
robot
if you have non-human life forms walking
around you could kill them though i will
i will warn you jessica okay it's
possible to seek a remedy in civil court
okay
so much like o.j simpson was acquitted
of of the murders he was still found
guilty in civil court so you can kill
groot but groot's family could come
after you and see compensatory damages
okay
it's mine
they could get all your money they could
take your house they could take your car
they could take your pension okay i got
it okay so like the purge right you
won't be in jail okay
god i'm bringing i will always bring
this back to the purge because that's
the only law i understand
you're always advocating for the
partnership it's not good to steal my
neighbor's tesla
and i need to make sure i can register
it uh-huh the autopilot doesn't work
it'll catch you on fire
get out of it yeah uh look it up you
guys the car doors don't open i'm gonna
get sued i'm gonna get sued by daddy
musk now
[Laughter]
anyway
one other thing that that is funny from
the comics using if you use magic in
financial dealings it it constitutes as
a legal market manipulation so i can't
wait so bad so if you use a spell to
like change the the stock market to make
more money that's illegal what about
money laundering
uh money laundering so you're taking is
this like um
you're taking money and you're using
magic to launder it like you're using
magic to take money that you got through
ill-gotten means and turn it into yeah
i guess it's still
money-laundering i think i think what
you should be doing you should learn
magic to turn stuff into gold i think
that's okay well yeah that seems better
anyways like uh turning it into like
jewelry and then pawn chopping it yeah
yeah cause they're not i think don't
even don't even bother with dirty money
like just turn stuff into money
so you're telling me to become a pirate
no no no no no which i'm telling you to
become a pro i'll do any second of the
day you know you know i love robin you
you know
you love robin you love mod uh maraudin
robin
and pilling newton and tuden baby that's
the only two things i need in this world
oh my god
you guys uh after that discussion i'm
gonna give you guys a shout out for our
merch right merch merch time merch time
i'm wearing our merch this is our moon
night merch yeah merch time
me and brandon actually have a ton of
merch uh be sure to check out
newrockstarsmerch.com to see all the
awesome merch options it's a great way
to support all the awesome work that we
do for your channel for your channel for
our channel and it's for everybody we're
we're in everybody's channel honestly uh
we just dropped our
newest limited edition latest obsession
shirt inspired by the new obi-wan kenobi
series and if you buy this shirt i don't
know why am i looking around like we're
in the office
if you have that the pretend this is it
if you have this shirt uh and if you buy
this shirt you unlock the ability to get
custom shout out that will appear on our
weekly wikileaks show hosted by eric
voss and my baby boy tommy bechtold like
all of our latest obsession merch it
will sell out fast so head over to
newrockstarsmerge.com today to grab
yours before it's lost in the sands of
tatooine but then we'll go back to
tattooing because we always do
we always do we just get off of tatooine
please never they will never leave
tattooing it'll get lost and then you
can go back you can go back and find it
oh and before we dive into our bite size
questions next some words from the
people that help bring us big question
do you avast has been a global leader in
cyber security for more than 30 years
entrusted by over 435 million users
avast empowers you with digital safety
and privacy no matter who you are where
you are or how you connect a vast new
all-in-one solution avast one helps you
take control of your safety and privacy
online through a range of features avast
offers a ton of features such as pc
speedup which optimizes the background
activity of your apps in order to speed
up your pc they also have smart scan
which will find and remove viruses and
resolve the most common privacy issues
and performance issues through an
optimization scan and their
award-winning anti-virus will stop
viruses and malware from harming your
machine avast one offers both free and
premium options i like their data breach
monitoring which lets you know when you
need to change passwords to your online
accounts that may have been compromised
sometimes those companies don't let you
know that your information may have been
leaked out but a vast one will and
that's why it's a great product we want
to thank avast for supporting big
question avast prevents over 1.5 billion
attacks every month and with a vast one
you can confidently take control of your
online world without worrying about
viruses phishing attacks ransomware
hacking attempts and other cyber crimes
learn more about avast one at avast.com
again that's avast.com and we think of
ask so much for supporting bigquestion
brandon yes jessica are you ready for a
bite-sized question
objection oh yes i am ready for a
bite-sized question overall
oh rules
i don't know any political
lawyer jargon um
you said hearsay hearsay i know that you
know women badgering the witness yeah
conspiracy conspiracy conspiracy
argument of your honor it's
argumentative uh recess recess
your honor may i approach the bench
that's a good one that's a good one you
with your improv knowledge all right
here's the first bite-sized question the
doctor strange and spider-man and
spider-man no way home caused an
incursion you've talked about this
before a gesso
that's why i put it in there you're good
at you're good at also summarizing this
you're gonna explain this okay this is
why
i don't think dr strange's spider-man
caused any incursions in spider-man in
their way home and here's why in doctor
strange of the multiverse of madness
okay they kind of set up that incursions
happened when people were dream walking
or they were messing with the dark hole
in general right they're using this dark
magic to go into other universes and
that's what was causing the incursions
okay we've talked about this before it's
a little confusing but you have like
different universes obviously separate
from each other uh and within those
universes you have multiple timelines
we know that dark magic comes from like
the dark dimension dark energy it all
comes from the dark dimension this is
talked about in doctor strange but the
ancient one she's drawing power from the
dark dimension it's how she's living for
a long time the dark dimension is a
dimension
wow and the dimensions kind of exist in
between the physical realms of the
universes so if you think about
universes hanging out there they're out
in space you have two separate universes
right in the middle okay it's like a
dimension that dimension can cross into
whatever universe it wants to cross into
okay you have that dark energy in that
dark matter that's in that dark
dimension
now when you are messing with the dark
cold okay you're drawing that power
you're going in and out you're causing
that that dimension that exists between
the two universes that you're dream
walking in between that dark energy it's
breaking down okay i think you're
causing problems and you're causing it
to bleed into like both dimensions and
it kind of creates this this suction
force that swaps them together okay
spiderman no way home that's not dark
magic they were doing eldrick magic
remember doctor strange says to huang
and one's like don't do that spell it's
dangerous he's like runes of kafka we do
this [ __ ] all the time
we have these parties and we're we're
throwing it up now you might seem that
sounds crazy right they were throwing up
this magic spell that messed with
people's minds and erased their memories
we have to remember
the 616 mcu up until the death of he who
remains was being very tightly
controlled okay it was being maintained
it was being pruned it was
kept away to keep it separate from all
the other universes to keep all the
other kangs out so he who remains could
live in peace and not have all this
infighting with his brothers okay
he who remains is dead sylvie did it
maybe she was right maybe she was wrong
i don't know okay this is the classic
neo in the matrix with the architect
question okay was it right was it wrong
doesn't matter he's dead now that
protection is gone i think what was
happening when they were doing that
ruins of kafka spell with other parties
or because they forgot a birthday or
whatever
that spell was going wrong all the time
but kang and the tva they were trimming
it they were keeping it safe and those
these uh
masters of the mystic arts they had no
idea how dangerous that spell was right
every time they did it had the potential
to go that wrong but it never went wrong
because there was protection
when spider-man shows up and he wants to
do the spell and he's like don't do the
spell we're gonna do a spell he's saying
stuff and he's messing it up and whose
fault is is it doctor strange's
spider-man doesn't matter daddy kang's
not there to keep it all safe okay and
they're pulling in people from other
universes that's what happened there but
because it wasn't dark magic i don't
think it caused an incursion because it
was done through like eldritch magic
okay that's my story and i'm sticking to
it okay
no incursions no such thing there's no
such thing as a dumb question period
there's no such thing as a dumb question
but if you guys ask me this question
ever again i'm going to point to brandon
to recite and give you exactly what it
is or just come watch this episode of
big question again the breakdown we
talked about in the breakdown so we're
going to talk about that in the
breakdown of the break room i do the
breakdown the break we're going to break
down
but we talk about it and if you're not
happy with that answer that's the only
answer i will ever give you is brandon's
answer because it makes complete sense
and it will br is brandon's answer
because it makes complete sense and i
can never summarize that for you it
makes sense right i like that it does no
it does make sense it makes complete
sense and that's why i was like oh no
that's it that's it there's people right
here that's like oh yeah 100 no that is
true correct is this correct that's
correct second one second question which
is honestly a hot question i have this
question everyone would probably also
ask this question how does wonder woman
age okay tell me how does she age okay i
was thinking about this um because like
all amazonians okay diana ages very
slowly the amazons were created by the
olympian gods okay the exact ones who
created them it kind of changes
depending on the story again they've
been writing these comics for a long
time things kind of adjust but it's some
combination of aphrodite artemis a theme
demeter and hestia right they made the
uh amazonians and basically because if
we saw the movie right you've seen a
young diana so clearly they're children
at some point the amazonians and then
they grow okay the way it works is the
way when you reach maturity or like
basically your physical prime you stop
aging so we saw like a young diana right
she runs that race uh and because she
wins the race she's like allowed to
become like a warrior whatever so
they're like the way i understand it is
like if if they're like oh you're you're
you you grow to your physical prime to
your your perfect point and then you
kind of stop aging from there
and you kind of gain
immortality from that point and your
aging appears to stop we saw in the
movie right on themyscira you had like
the young ones i guess they grow to
their physical prime some of the elders
looked a little older right they don't
look like they're all at gal gadot's age
right like some of them are older than
that maybe that's like their physical
prime they got to that age and they're
like okay now you're at your prime yeah
i don't know how that all works exactly
and there's been some versions of the
story because she leaves the mascara
right she's not allowed to come back
that she there's one version where she
sacrifices her aging so she can be with
steve trevor it kind of changes all over
the place but the way i understand it is
like as an amazonian you get to this
point and then you kind of like stop
aging and the way it's i've seen it is
like you're not like immortal forever
you're just you're very hard to kill
you're like immune from natural aging
and death
you're not immune you're not immune from
like a god killer okay modern modern
wonder woman specifically is a demigod
in in in her incarnation right now right
she's the daughter of zeus and hippolyta
originally in the comics uh she had no
father she was like sculpted from clay
because hippolyta wanted her daughter so
bad but now she's like half god so that
kind of adds to her immortality a little
bit but again she's not completely
invulnerable from death if someone was
able to kill a demigod by violent means
they could kill her uh but the way i
understand she's not gonna die from old
age so that's kind of how it works you
age up to a point and then you stop
aging which sounds lovely doesn't that
sound great i would love that i would
love that who wouldn't love that who
wouldn't love that i have i haven't
gotten that yet i haven't even begun to
peek jessica
[Music]
i haven't baby i'm
you sound like dennis from it's always
sitting in philadelphia you're a mad man
and a crazy person
um are we ready for our box of scraps oh
i'm ready for a blog
where the box is crazy it didn't give me
the basic scrapes
i rewatched that damn clip of box of
scraps but i watched the entire movie
just for that clip oh yeah yeah
i forgot that he was like yelling at
that poor man
he comes out of nowhere it comes out of
nowhere the boy from a christmas story
just gets harassed damn well it was
boss's idea to make that clip the
introduced
fox crap that was epic oh that was good
so it's like we watched we were
re-watching the sam remy spider-man and
the whole
first the first spider-man i'm laughing
at so many random points and carrie's
like why are you laughing i'm like
that's a meme that's a meme that's a
meme i rewatched that first spider-man
and i was like oh no
it's hard watching it because when i was
younger i was like this is the best
thing i've ever seen
i mean yeah
it's not terrible i mean they held up
all right yeah they hold up fine so did
the first x-men movie but it's also not
the best the first x-men now is riff
oof
i'm a first class girl okay so our box
is scratch correct question what
fictional lawyer would you want to
represent you and i want to say mine
first before you steal it do it do it um
i wanted to be the lawyer in chicago
billy what is it uh billy flynn billy
flint billy flynn
i wanted to be i don't care about
expensive things cashmere coats diamond
rings don't mean a thing
all i like
[Music]
that's what he's here for that's all i
want ellie flynn would be a great one
because even if i did do it he'd give me
off
he wouldn't get you he would get you off
you get me off oh yeah who whoever
saul goodman's a great choice i think
but i would like i would love to go i
would love to go classic with it i mean
i want matlock up there
you know what i'm talking about well my
boy matlock
little southern lawyership going on oh
no that's what i wanted
any of the people from law order none of
us said uh no no no no
the law and order people they're batting
average ain't great they lose their
badges they lost
ain't losing no cases
and he's going to sing while he does it
he's here for he's here for the women
he's here for the women he's here for
the women that are going to jail for
murdering
yeah yeah she's unloved she's been
mistreated she's been neglected what do
you expect her to do jazz you guys
that was the big question
thank you brandon for
inviting me but also thank you for
joining
thank you for inviting me and joining me
oh my god follow uh brandon on twitter
at grin and barrack
follow me at lulu underscore clemens
both both punny names um his makes more
sense if you don't know athlete's
athletic leisure where
follow new rockstars add new rockstars
here on youtube and on all social media
platforms make sure to hit that
notification bell like subscribe follow
be sure to check out our new new
rockstars discord server and don't
forget to check out our tumblr that i'm
running that i'm running and i talk to
you i talk to you guys and on that
tumblr account i go harass everybody at
work and tell them the questions and i'm
gonna respond to you guys with their
answers as well so if you wanted to
respond if you wanted to get a shout out
from tommy on tumblr or brandon or zack
or boss or md or whitney or me
go to that tumblr go to it be sure to
check it out have a nice night have a
nice evening goodbye yeah bye go break
some laws
go break those laws
bad boys bad boys what you're gonna do
can we can we
is that illegal
we can put ten seconds of it and then we
gotta go let's do twelve then we do it
then we'll be actually
drew make sure to end this segment with
bad boys please
[Music]
you
[Music]